Garlic is widely cultivated in
California, especially in the Gilroy
region. Known as the garlic capital of
the world with its dry climate, fertile
soil, and advanced farming practices,
California has become the largest garlic
producing state in the US. Garlic is not
only an essential culinary ingredient,
but also a high-v value agricultural
product, contributing hundreds of
millions of dollars to the US economy
each year through both domestic
consumption and export. Despite advances
in agricultural technology, garlic
harvesting is still primarily done by
hand. Immigrant laborers with swift and
resilient hands bend under the scorching
sun to pull each bulb from the ground,
clean it, and sort it on site. These
skilled workers are an indispensable
part of the agricultural supply chain,
playing a vital role in maintaining the
quality and volume of garlic production
across the United States.
[Music]
Planting garlic using modern machinery
has significantly improved efficiency
and reduced manual labor. Across the
vast fields of California, specialized
garlic planters are used to evenly
distribute garlic cloves into
wellprepared soil beds. These machines
precisely control the spacing and depth
of each clove, ensuring optimal
conditions for growth. Thanks to this
technology, multiple hectares of garlic
can be planted within just a few hours,
saving both time and labor costs while
maintaining consistency and productivity
in large-scale farming operations.
[Music]
[Applause]
Under the scorching sun of California's
central valley, known as the garlic
capital of America, thousands of
immigrant workers bend over rows of
soil, skillfully pulling garlic bulbs
from the
[Music]
[Applause]
earth. While some large farms have
adopted mechanized harvesting systems,
most small and medium farms still rely
heavily on hand harvesting. Garlic is a
delicate crop that can be easily damaged
if not handled carefully, making manual
labor
[Music]
essential. These farm workers are
primarily immigrants from countries like
Mexico, Guatemala, El Salvador, and
Honduras. Many have fled poverty and
hardship, crossing borders in search of
a better life. Most lack legal
documentation or work temporarily under
the H2A agricultural visa program. They
often live in crowded makeshift housing
and save every penny to send back to
their families.
[Music]
Harvesting garlic by hand is grueling
work. Laborers start at dawn and work
until evening, constantly bending,
pulling garlic from the soil, brushing
off dirt, trimming roots and leaves, and
placing the bulbs into large crates. It
demands stamina, speed, and precision.
Wages typically range from $14 to $18
per hour, DAR, depending on the state
and the farm's policies. Skilled and
fast workers can earn up to $20 $20 per
hour, but at the cost of physical
exhaustion, back pain, and blistered
hands.
[Music]
Despite modest wages, after deducting
housing, transportation, health care,
and remittances, little is left for
savings. Their lives are quiet,
resilient, and filled with sacrifice.
Each garlic bulb they harvest represents
not just a crop, but a drop of sweat, a
dream, and a hope for a better future.
Though rarely featured in headlines,
these laborers are the silent heroes of
American agriculture. Nameless hands
that cultivate and gather the land's
finest fruits.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
[Applause]
[Music]